PornHub is the largest most mainstream
porn company in the world it's owned by
a parent company called Mind geek
and mind geek is now being sued into
Oblivion and this is a really good thing
the parent company of PornHub is being
sued by a minor child's mother because
this porn website
allowed the dis allegedly allowed the
dissemination of videos and images of
her little son being sexually molested
by an Alabama man this is despite
warnings from the authorities to Pornhub
Pornhub still allowed this video to go
out there and so it's I mean it's so
sick it's so nauseating to think that
this is out there that it's legal
I think it's a kind of dubious legality
that PornHub is even allowed to exist
but it's tolerated at least by the law
enforcement authorities and that it's
making a lot of money
that's awful and so conservatives need
to support this being shut down any way
that we can
you'll they were dealt a tough blows
some months ago when credit card
companies stopped doing business with
mind geek because of these kind of
allegations of child pornography and the
more libertarian-minded conservatives a
lot of them said no it's absolutely we
need to defend pornhub's right to spread
filth around the world and addict little
kids to pornography but the conservative
said okay good shut it down shut it down
what percentage of my mailbag is young
man writing into me saying they've got
sex problems because they were exposed
to porn when they were kids
a large percentage of it when people
come up to me at colleges and
universities that's often a a problem
that they will bring up
it's just it's just awful it's awful
obviously for the people being abused in
the movies it's awful for the people who
are being addicted to the smut it's
awful for society that we're tolerating
this at all and for what
for the right
of these perverts to exploit little
children to make an extra Buck there's
no right to that you don't have a right
to that at all you whatever to there was
a lot more wrong with PornHub than the
fact that there's child pornography on
it there's a lot more in addition to
that that is wrong
but if the child porn thing is what's
going to take him down fine by me use
whatever we can do horrible terrifying
news coming out of Canada and Canada is
usually at the avant-garde here
America's top hat is usually just a few
steps ahead of where we are headed so
you've got to be prepared for this to to
come to the United States we got to
fight at Tooth and Nail Canada is now
encouraging mentally ill people to kill
themselves
Canada has just passed
an assisted suicide right the Canadian
Supreme Court discovered some right to
kill yourself of course there is no
right to kill yourself because there's
no right to do wrong and and killing
oneself is a is a grave grave sin and a
violation of the law of
self-preservation and it's just
absolutely no bueno uh but one one of
the arguments against assisted suicide
even the softest Arguments for it well
what if someone is an intense pain and
they've got a fatal illness terminal
illness that they're certainly going to
die from very soon don't you think it's
all right to just kind of up the drugs
and kill them
and I don't think that that's right at
all but that that argument works on a
lot of people then one of the arguments
against that is well it's a slippery
slope it's a very slippery slope and
pretty soon it's not just going to be
those terminally ill cancer patients on
the brink of death in intense pain who
are opting for doctor-assisted suicide
pretty soon it's going to be people who
are younger who are a little healthier
who are depressed who have mental
illness who are poor and now you're
seeing this play out right now in Canada
afraid to die who isn't
yeah I mean it it uh
Amir farsood has applied for medically
assisted dying known as maid he lives in
constant Agony due to a back injury but
has started the process for end of life
because his rooming house is up for sale
and he can't find anywhere else to live
that he can afford he barely survives on
Ontario Disability support payments
which are just over twelve hundred
dollars a month he doesn't want to die
but being homeless is not an option I
know in my present health condition I
would survive It Anyway farsood meets
the criteria for made physical suffering
due to disability that cannot be
relieved his doctor who knows farsoud's
real reason for maid is his fear of
being homeless signed off on the
application in August farsood needs a
second to do the same there's a 90-day
waiting period he believes he could
potentially access made in about a month
I don't wish to be dead
um even with the pain even with the meds
um I still want to be here
only the most evil society would
tolerate this
and encourage this I mean this this is
as evil as it gets
we we talk about the Nazis you know we
invoke the Nazis in every single
historical comparison that anyone makes
because they don't have any historical
frame of reference
telling our most vulnerable people
killing off our most vulnerable people
that is that is whatever you accuse the
Nazis of that is that is it that is it
we are the baddies if we do that
we are as bad as it
can possibly get
if we do this
we're already pretty bad we kill 850 000
babies a year here in the United States
and then on top of that we're going to
kill our elderly our poor elderly if
you've ever had an aging relative
you know that at when it comes to later
stages of life
people feel they're a burden on their
families people feel there's a big cost
they need to be taken care of a lot more
they get depressed
I'm sure if this were an option many
many people out of a feeling of Despair
and guilt for putting their family
through some difficulty would take this
it's not as though if you legalize made
that's the new euphemism they're calling
it
it's just assisted suicide
which which is just suicide it's suicide
but but it's even more evil because it's
got the complicity of the public health
establishment
complete violation of the Hippocratic
oath and of sort of basic tenets of of
good political communities
if you legalize this stuff it's not that
you're just going to get a few Fringe
cases of people who are really thinking
rationally and who just really have made
a calculated serious decision to kill
themselves
it's going to spread like wildfire
it's going to be every old granny who
feels that she's just a burden to her
family she's going to do it she's going
to feel pressured to do it every
mentally ill person in a fit of insanity
is going to do it every poor person who
doesn't want to live on the street but
can't afford to to make ends meet
is going to do it
every depressed person teenagers
children are doing this right now in
Europe in the Netherlands
Belgium
it's gonna it's going to spread like
wildfire and it is so it is the most
evil thing I can think of
this sort of thing
and the fact that you heard that doctor
signed off on it
the doctor knew that the man no doctor
should sign off on this ever if a doctor
signs off on assisted suicide he should
have his license revoked
has violated the Hippocratic Oath but
the doctor knows that this guy's just
killing himself because he fears poverty
and homelessness and instead of saying
hey
I'm going to refer you to this agency
that's going to find you a home instead
of saying hey here's a check I'm a
doctor I make a decent amount of money
actually with Canada socialist
Healthcare probably not but at least
someone's saying hey here I don't have
much but here's what money I can give
you hey don't kill yourself here's money
to pay rent instead of doing that like a
decent human being would do he says okay
here you go kill yourself and you got
you got to wait 90 days I'm sorry but
then bye see ya
doctor I don't want to die but I feel I
I don't have options oh okay then die
just go die go kill yourself
but we're the good guys right we're the
good guys we're not like those bad guys
you know it's amazing the moral preening
you hear from us in the West
oh okay at least we're not like Putin
Putin's a bad guy we're the good guy at
least we're not like Xi Jinping Xi
Jinping He's the bad guy
we are slaughtering babies and telling
the the poor people to kill themselves
rather than giving them alms
it's as evil as can be
and it's The Logical conclusion of
individualism by the way that's the
other thing this is why we're not immune
to it this is why even the right kind of
goes along with this sometimes because
yes the end of leftism is suicide we
know that we are yes we ex we understand
that that is what leftism is about is
just destroying everything burning it
all to the ground but it's it's the end
of individualism true there are a lot of
people on the right
who accept a very liberal premises of
individualism the idea that I own my
body that I'm answerable only to me I
can do whatever I have a natural
individual right to do whatever the hell
I want especially with my own body you
don't that's not conservative that has
no basis in the
proper Western tradition
that is an outgrowth of liberalism and
it's not true
it's not true you
don't choose to be born into this world
you shouldn't choose to come out of this
world you are not accountable only to
yourself
you have obligations to your family to
your community and ultimately to your
God
today we will be discovering all sorts
of new genders on tick tock
I usually interview people on on
Tuesdays but you know listen today today
is all about Trump's announcement we're
going to be talking later on for that so
I figured we needed to mix it up a
little bit get some open our minds on
these questions of gender the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]